eric um
how long did it take uh between the
celebration the other night from
advancing to the finals
and everybody kind of digging back in to
what you guys need to do now going
forward
we did take a night just to acknowledge
it
and enjoy it
you know the players and the staff and
families that were here
i really do want i wanted everybody you
know to have perspective on
how difficult this is how extraordinary
of a
experience all of this is being part of
this bubble of being here for
80 plus days surviving all of it and
earning the right to compete for
an nba title um but we just got off a
very competitive hard fought
series and you know emotionally i don't
think anybody is ready just to
turn that page but yesterday was a work
day for the players it was a day just to
recover and relax and
we got together last night and did some
more prep today
next question tom deangelo hey eric
hey tom hey uh eric how is lebron
different today than he was the last
time he wore a heat uniform
uh you know i don't know but i i just
think it
is a true testament uh to his greatness
uh to be able to sustain this type of
success uh year in year out
different uh uniforms
uh and everybody you know new new
players and new teams
you know going after them uh
uh it's it's a real testament uh to that
commitment
um you know he's he's seen everything
you know at this point uh in his career
uh it's
it's just about winning and
his ability to do what he does
at his age is
is incredibly uncommon um but there's
there's a lot of work that goes behind
the scenes um
you know to be able to maintain that
next question kyle tucker from the
athletic
go ahead kyle i'm sorry about that uh
i know you've this has been talked about
before but uh
you guys you got a couple kentucky guys
there uh
one one's a boss and two have been a
huge part of this run
and you've i know you've sort of
addressed it but
what is it about kentucky guys do you
think they're the two you have anyway
and about their kentucky experience do
you think that has prepared them
to be ready for such a stage so soon
well we have to have a few kentucky guys
on our team
because my boss that's like a
prerequisite
uh somehow someway we got to get
somebody uh from
his alma mater on on our roster uh
this seems this final seems like a
great recruiting pitch for cal doesn't
it and i'm
i'm not sure he's going to maximize that
we we love kentucky players because
you're there
to get better to be pushed uh to
understand
uh what it means uh to play for our team
play
play a role uh and to train
uh to become a pro at this level you're
going to face good competition in
practice
you're going to be expected to work and
it's a it's an environment that as much
as it
possibly can prepare you
for the pros even though it's at the
collegiate level
you know our two guys played
significantly different roles
for kentucky when they're in college and
that was part of the thing that we liked
they're both willing to play a role
young players often times it's just
about
how many shots they can get how many
touches scores
so they can improve their draft process
but if you just watch all of those
games of tyler and bam
you know when we when we met with them
they both said hey we're
capable of doing more but you always
take that with a grain of salt every
player says that
but they truly did just commit to to a
role and
worked like crazy behind the scenes uh
on their player development
and it's been obviously just a
a good fit with us their mentality and
how we are
in person tim reynolds on your right
spo so much got made and much still gets
made about how lebron changed after
2011.
how much did going through that change
you
as well i mean it seemed like that's
when there was like a further commitment
to position lists and
putting together guys as groups instead
of just individuals and figuring how you
can play guys
as five instead of where one guy would
fit it just seemed like a lot of change
with you that off season too
how much did going through that help you
out as well
those are great professional and life
experiences
to be able to have that opportunity to
grow and
you know the first two teams i coached
as a head coach were
much different than that whole
experience and the game started to
change
you know during that run and we had to
adapt and adjust
accordingly but you know i learned and
grew
in the nba in the 90s
under pat and then the early 2000s you
look at those
games systematically and schematically
and just
stylistically to compare where it is
right now it's
two different sports so i'm just very
grateful that i had that opportunity to
be able to
to grow and
be on that journey with that group that
was
an amazing team and everything that came
about it
um in many ways just my personality
i hated it and
you know i'm an introvert so i don't
like you know that but i think it was
good to go through that sometimes you
know even as a professional just to get
out of your comfort zone and
embrace it and and see what happens when
you get out on the other side of it
it was it feels like a totally different
chapter in my life but i'm
truly grateful to be around uh those
special players that
group that was so committed uh to coming
together to compete for titles
dave here on the front eric how long did
it take you to come to terms
um back in 2014 after lebron left to
recognize
you know that there's going to be
another chapter and then what's been
like to see him
make five more finals appearances since
you guys part at least
uh yeah the the
first part of that uh you know we went
through the whole process i went through
my own
you know six week uh reflection period
uh that summer um but then you get back
to work that's
we've we've built a lot of different
teams over the years and
and we've been conditioned
to to move on and give everything your
heart and soul to the next
group and the next team and we really
thought that we had
a championship contending team that next
year
that's how we approached it
however doesn't it's irrelevant what
anybody else thought we knew
that we were losing um but when we made
that mid-season trade for gorham we made
a problem promise to him that we would
be competing for titles
it was just so unfortunate uh that cb
wasn't able to finish the season but we
owed it to goran to fight for it and go
for it and we ended up
fighting for the playoffs dwayne missed
25 games but we were just there at the
end
we got knocked out of the playoffs with
um three days to go
but you gained that experience i think
it was important to show gorn that we
are not going to tank and we're going to
continue to build and
the next year was uh the year that we
were able to go to game seven we thought
that was a
legit contending team and we had that
just really really tough seven game
series with toronto weren't able to make
it to the conference finals
to play against cleveland we thought
we really had a chance uh that year
um and that's what this game does to you
sometimes it breaks your heart
uh that that you really broke our heart
we thought we
we really had a good run in us
um and that was the second year that's
where
cb again had had to step away
uh but then to see you know what
lebron has done when he moved on to
cleveland and to hear
it really is just a testament to uh
his greatness and his commitment to
winning
and to be able to do it uh with
different rosters
and uniforms is is really remarkable
thank you coach goran will be right up
thank you